now for those saying  you know david sir cases don't matter if  people aren't getting sick if people  aren't getting hospitalized well i  already told you deaths are up 70  but hospitalizations are also way up  compared to a year ago hospitalizations  are about 300 percent higher  around 100 000 we only had about 30 000  people hospitalized with covid a year  ago so what are the indicators in our  favor if there are any  one is that relative to cases deaths  aren't as high and what i mean by that  is  deaths when we had this level of cases  previously deaths were higher cases are  up 300 percent but deaths are only up 70  that means each case is less likely to  lead to death  because  half the country is now vaccinated but  of course too many people are not